Historically, the fact that this property is called .prototype,
has been very confusing for people learning JavaScript.
By using this word to describe the methods container object,
that's available on every function,
JavaScript introduces an ambiguous 2nd meaning for the word prototype.
So if someone says, object one’s prototype is object two,
a reasonable interpretation would be to think that field lookups on this
first object should fall through to the second one.
So, you might say Amy's prototype is Car.prototype, but
this is not the relationship that Car has with Car.prototype.
In that case, Car is a function object and field lookups on it will fall through
to some function prototype, where all function objects delegate their field lookups.
The Car function’s relationship with Car.prototype is very different from
the one that Amy has with Car.prototype.
This other relationship reflects the second interpretation of the statement,
"object one's prototype is object two".
The relationship is that when a Car function runs,
it will create objects that delegate their field lookups to Car.prototype.
So in this sense, you might say, Car’s prototype is Car.prototype.
So to review, saying Amy's prototype is
Car.prototype means something very different from saying Car’s prototype is
Car.prototype even though those sentences look so similar.
We can leave this discussion behind, but
be aware that it's extremely easy to conflate these two uses of
the word prototype, and it's well worth investing extra thought in ironing out
exactly what the differences between the two uses are.